guten abend oder guten tag meine damen
und herren spielplanänderungen heißt der
titel der diskussion die wir jetzt
gleich führen werden
damit war ursprünglich verbunden
eigentlich die idee stücke die selten
oder gar nie gespielt werden vorschlagen
und darüber zu sprechen warum sie nicht
gespielt werden
ob sie gespielt werden sollten was in
ihnen drin steckt zweimal haben wir es
versucht die pandemie hat uns einen
strich durch die rechnung gemacht aber
jetzt findet trotzdem eine diskussion
statt oder demselben titel aber zu einem
anderen thema nämlich die große spiel
planänderung die im augenblick
stattfindet nämlich das gar nicht
gespielt wird wir sind jetzt in dem
zweiten lok darunter den light genannt
wird
wir wissen nicht wann das endet aber wir
wissen dass im augenblick eben die
theater die oper die bühnen insgesamt
genauso zusieht wie die museen und
andere veranstaltungen aus dem bereich
der kunst und darüber wollen wir jetzt
ein bisschen diskutieren was das heißt
ob das richtig so ist welche
einschätzung von kultur damit einher
geht
und ich stelle ihnen die gäste vor die
hier mit mir diskutieren werden mein
name ist glaube ich kümmere mich in der
faz um das töten
dörte lyssewski schauspielerin aus wien
angereist
klaus lederer kultursenator berlins und
auch für europa zuständig thomas
oberender der intendant der berliner
festspiele und ein autor
ich fange mal an einfach fröhlich selbst
kiwi was machen sie zur zeit
ich darf
an dem geänderten programm gerade
teilnehmen hier in der wunderbaren
volksbühne
ansonsten denke ich darüber nach wie es
weitergeht weil ich habe derzeit keine
proben ich glaube das ist jetzt mit der
jetzigen stunde auch geändert ich habe
gerade gehört dass es einen harten
lockdown jetzt gibt in österreich vor
einer stunde oder so das heißt bis jetzt
durften wir proben spielen nicht das
wird jetzt glaube ich auch hinfällig
sein das heißt jetzt muss man die zeit
nutzen darüber nachzudenken wie man mit
dieser neuen situation die sich noch
lange hinziehen wird umgeht denn
nichtstun und abwarten kann es meines
erachtens nach nicht sein
ist es eigentlich so als schauspielerin
dass man das gefühl hat man verliert
wenn man nicht grob bei musikern liegt
das immer nahe zu sagen wenn die nicht
proben können dann dann dann dann kostet
es irgendwie einen die fähigkeit wie ist
das im schauspiel das ist vielleicht
nicht zu erwarten aber das ist exakt
dasselbe das heißt die das training die
elastizität die beweglichkeit von
gedanken von gefühlen vom körper der
rhein sportive effekt des ganzen also im
weitesten sinne sportiv das spürt man
wenn man das nicht tut
zumal das einem berufs oder eine
tätigkeit ist die sich immer im
austausch mit anderen befindet in
energien mit anderen wenn diese energie
fehlt das spürt man sofort weil ein ein
vakuum greift und eine art von inklusion
die ist sehr unangenehm denn ein
schauspieler der spielt und tut ist ein
schauspieler der spielt und den
schauspieler vom sofa sitzt kein
schauspieler sie wie soll ich sagen
verantworten hätte doch dauernd nicht
aber sie sind an seiner umsetzung
beteiligt wie sehen sie das
wie wie sehen sie insbesondere auch die
wie soll ich sagen die die begründung
die seitens der bühnen gekommen sind
dass man sich doch so sehr um den
hygiene hygiene konzepte gekümmert hat
und abstand dass man als doch sehr viel
wert darauf gelegt hat der der
gesundheitspolitischen situation
rechnung zu tragen und und gleichwohl
jetzt die bühnen geschlossen sind und
die kaufhäuser offen also erstmal
verantwortlich den lockdown natürlich in
der weise schon mit als die
landesregierung das ganze am ende in
rechtsverordnungen gießen oder in enorm
gießen und ich habe hier mehr zugestimmt
im senat ich habe nicht gesagt nein ich
mache das nicht mit weil die steigenden
ansteckungszahlen sind ja erst mal ein
fakt so und das argumenten haben wir uns
sieben monate vorbereitet ist einerseits
richtig relativiert sich andererseits
wenn wir wissen dass die kontakt
beschränkung ja nicht nur die situation
in den einrichtungen selbst betreffen
sondern offensichtlich das ziel ja auch
darin besteht das gesellschaftliche
leben zu verlangsamen insgesamt weniger
verkehr zu erzeugen wenn ich das mal so
sagen darf also das ist zumindest der
hintergrund des ganzen
angesichts der belastungssituation im
gesundheitswesen und trotzdem bleibt
natürlich bei mir auch ein nachgeschmack
und der hat verschiedene verschiedene
richtungen ich will jetzt mal nur eine
raus greifen als jurist kann man das gut
und ist da dann auf der sicheren seite
die begründung die nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz kam war die
das versammlungsfreiheit gottesdienste
religionsausübung grundgesetzlich
geschützt sind das ist ja eine
verfassungs wertung und dass deswegen
bei grund bei diesen grundrechts
geneigten bereichen einschränkungen
jetzt nicht tun sich waren so da ist
ganz nebenbei natürlich die kunst
vergessen worden dann auch die
kunstfreiheit ist eine
verfassungsrechtlich geschützte
betätigung und das hat gute gründe weil
man in einer offenen in einer
demokratischen gesellschaft der kunst
offenbar eine rolle zu spricht die jetzt
über das reine freizeitvergnügen
hinausgeht von dem ja in dieser
pressekonferenz die rede war also man
geht davon aus es gibt eine
gesellschaftliche
funktion von kunst und wenn man das
sozusagen mit einer seiten bemerkung
abtut
das hier freizeit jetzt ist nicht die
zeit für freizeit und geselligkeit dann
verkennt dass ganz offensichtlich diese
gesellschaftliche funktion von kunst und
da muss man gar keinen großen partners
an den tag legen ich finde das
problematisch dass das so diskussionslos
so 163 gemacht worden ist
mit allen konsequenzen da spielt für
mich jetzt noch mal die frage wie viel
mühe sich in den letzten sieben monaten
gegeben wurde oder die soziale situation
der kunstschaffenden spielt auch eine
rolle aber es spielt gar nicht die
vordergründige rolle weil das problem
haben andere gesellschaftliche bereiche
natürlich auch also auch gastronomen und
gastronomen haben den letzten sieben
monaten waren die nicht untätig sein
haben versucht ihre ihre ihre ihre läden
kohler fest zu machen wenn man das so
sagen
also was man was was bei mir unbehagen
auslöst ist die tatsache dass im diskurs
die kunst so relativ umstandslos dem in
einer solchen krisensituation
überflüssigen oder jetzt mal für eine
weile außer kraft zu setzen
freizeitvergnügen subsumiert wird und da
sage ich mal wenn man sagt der
gottesdienst ist ein ort oder
religionsausübung ist ein ort der
sinnsuche der der individuellen
bearbeitung auch von krisensituationen
der trifft das zumindest für die kunst
auch zu denn auch sie hilft erkenntnis
suche auch sie ist hat ein momentum von
sinnsuche und gerade in
krisensituationen würde ich behaupten
hat es eine besondere relevanz
ja und das ist mein unbehagen ja würden
sie denken dass vielleicht der grund
dafür ist also die für die
unterschiedliche bearbeitung des themas
religion im verhältnis zur kunst
das ist ein gottesdienst sich besser
abgrenzen lässt als alle möglichen arten
der kunst ausübung weil es weil es ja
ein man könnte sagen es gibt ein
kontinuum von einem ja von einem
popkonzert zu einem zu einer aufführung
der braut von messina und und das ist
beim gottesdienst doch wie soll man
sagen eingrenzbar ist das der grund
gewesen dass man das gemacht
also wenn wir davon ausgehen dass dieser
all diese maßnahmen mit einer pandemie
situation begründet werden
dann ist wohl nur undifferenzierte
teilung das eine vom anderen einfach
nicht haltbar weil man könnte natürlich
auch in der kunst sagen es gibt
bestimmte betätigung bei denen ist alles
was wir über die pandemie wissen in
besonderer weise gefährden also
geschlossene räume oder
belüftungsanlagen die klubs sind seit
märz zu vergegenwärtigen wir uns das mal
so da gab es nie zwischendurch eine
phase der öffnung so also man könnte
schon auch sagen es gibt bestimmte
epidemiologisch besondere
gefahrensituationen das lassen wir jetzt
mal weg haben wir in der vergangenheit
weggelassen und es gibt andere dinge die
sind relativ unbedenklich also der
wertungswiderspruch tut sich sofort auf
wenn ich eben sage ich kann in eine
galerie gehen um ein bild zu kaufen ja
wenn ich über das nötige geld verfügen
weil die kommerziellen galerien dem
einzelhandel zu gerechnet sind und
folglich offen sind
ich kann aber zur gleichen zeit nicht in
eine galerie gehen um dem beladen zu
schauen weil die nicht kommerziellen
galerien gehören eben zur kultur die
kultur ist nun mal gerade also da sieht
man sozusagen dass es zumindest in der
im erklären dessen was wir da tun und
politik ist ja veranlasst die maßstäbe
warum sie dinge tut offenzulegen oder
auch zur diskussion zu stellen
zumindest einer demokratischen
gesellschaft dann zeigt sich ganz
deutlich dass die und differenziertheit
der maßnahmen da nicht bis ins letzte
epidemiologische grund weil es ja
oberender wie sieht sie das bevor wir
vielleicht auf andere aspekte von corona
kommen die das theater betreffen wie
sehen sie das als jemand der ja auch
letztlich davon betroffen ist
ja ich finde natürlich auch viel besser
wenn museen und theater offen sind und
es trifft uns hart dass wir den
kuppelbau
schließen müssen das trifft uns hart
dass wir festivals an denen wir ein jahr
lang gearbeitet haben als reine online
veranstaltungen durchführen müssen
aber ich will mal so sagen eine andere
perspektive einnehmen und sagen dass die
politische entscheidung für mich absolut
klar und verantwortungsvoll getroffen
wurde und die entscheidung ist eine der
kontakt reduzierung es geht nicht um
konzepte und wie sicher sozusagen orte
und einrichtungen sind sondern es geht
darum und bestimmten gesellschaftlichen
verkehr zu minimieren
und dann muss man sich überlegen welche
bereiche in der gesellschaft dafür das
opfer bringen und man hat sich
entschieden zu sagen die wirtschaft und
die bildung nicht und der
freizeitbereich und das ist nicht
wertend gemeint weniger und da ist es so
dass ich auch das gefühl habe das
natürlich das unendlich abgestuft in der
schicksals härte ist also wir haben wir
haben glaube ich einen großen
institution eine situation wo wir alle
sichere gehaltsempfänger bleiben
es gibt wirklich große initiativen des
staates sowohl im bereich der
gastronomie wie auch der kultur zu
helfen und zwar abgestuft und schnell
und eigentlich relativ unkompliziert
also was man jetzt bis hin zu den hilfen
für solo selbstständige die nicht mehr
nur betriebskosten sondern auch
lebensunterhalt geltend machen können
also ich finde wir leben in einem land
was relativ rücksichtsvoll und und
elastisch reagiert und mir ist diese
reaktion im grunde lieber als ein
totaler lockdown und ich freue mich im
moment in deutschland zu leben und nicht
in frankreich oder in anderen ländern
also dass ich finde eigentlich man muss
die politik loben auch wenn wir jetzt
hier zu den zielen die opfer bringen und
die
betroffen sind in der stärkeren weise
als leute die vielleicht noch mal zur
arbeit gehen können und ich wünsche mir
natürlich dass das baldmöglichst wieder
so ist aber erstmal muss ich sagen dass
ich sehr beeindruckt bin von diesen
krisen management das in österreich auch
so formulieren
ich glaube nicht natürlich ist man im
land der seligen weil man bis jetzt also
wie gesagt bis vor einer stunde noch so
arbeiten konnte
auf der anderen seite bin ich das
irgendwie ein bisschen leid als
sonderfall behandelt zu werden und nicht
nur weil wir der freizeit zugeordnet
werden und ein staatsoperndirektor
gleichgestellt wird mit irgendeinem
bademeister irgendwo sondern weil es die
rechtfertigung gegenüber der
gesellschaft also gerade wenn von
wirtschaft gesprochen wird und ein ikea
dass ich den namen nenne offen haben
darf ich meine das jetzt gar nicht
populistisch mein theater geschlossen
wird aber zum einen haben lässt sich das
bei unseren institutionen
wir sind unter observation also und zwar
um das verhalten war vorbildlich nicht
nur wegen irgend welche investitionen in
belüftungs programme corona tests der
mitarbeiter das publikum hat sich
fantastisch verhalten auf der bühne
hinter der bühne
dass es überhaupt kein thema wir sind
einfach auch ein riesen
wirtschaftsfaktor und zwar nicht nur wie
das theater sondern die kultur insgesamt
also ich kann nur für österreich
sprechen aber da waren die zahlen in den
letzten jahren so an wertschöpfung der
kultur um sechs milliarden euro beläuft
man sich so bald bei drei prozent der
der leistung des staates das ist nicht
nichts
das heißt nicht dass man nicht
vernünftig handeln sollen ich bin auch
gegen irgendeine waage empörung weil
sich künstler gerne empören
ich möchte nur nicht unter diesen
ständigen rechtfertigungszwang kommen
wenn bei uns sachen sehr geordnet
ablaufen und in einem supermarkt nicht
oder in einem möbelhaus nicht dann
stellt man sich fragen und ich stellen
wir uns jetzt und es ist auch die frage
weshalb wenn ich die chance bekommen das
kann man jetzt vielleicht imk landes
dienen unter im lockdown machen dass man
andere konzepte entwickelt andere
formate
entwickelt ich selber arbeiten im großen
haus was halbwegs abgesichert ist das
stimmt schon
trotzdem wird uns das ja noch länger
begleiten das heißt ich glaube es kommt
jetzt darauf an dass man einfach gewisse
strukturen für die zeit dieser
ausnahmesituation über bord wirft und
anders darüber nachdenkt und dafür auch
möglichkeiten bekommt nicht nur weil wir
diesen bildungsauftrag haben sondern
weil diese althergebrachte nach dem
motto wenn es nicht so machen können wir
es bis jetzt gemacht haben dann machen
wir gar nichts und lassen uns schließen
und verlegen es jetzt nicht nur ins
internet sondern versuchen andere formen
auch wenn du wird wieder aufmachen
dürfen zu finden sei es dass man
vielleicht weniger repertoire macht mehr
ensuite spielt das falls wieder ein
lockdown kommt wenigstens nur eine
produktion gekühlt wird und nicht ein
ganzer ganzes repertoire per du ist und
damit ich weiß nicht wie viel millionen
euro also man kann ja anfangen neu
nachzudenken auch neu nachzudenken über
so etwas was es heißt ensemble ich
selber gehört zu der generation wir
mussten zunehmend mit jedem jahrzehnt
mehr jets hätten und setzen damit man ja
überall vorkommt usw
wenn das jetzt nicht geht dann kann man
jammern oder man kann es nutzen und
sagen gut wir stärken die einzelnen orte
die einzelnen theater wir stärken die
flexibilität verlegen das nach draußen
das ist immer eine frage der behörden
was man alles darf oder nicht aber meine
letzte erfahrung hier an dem haus das
jetzt zwölf jahre her da wurde gerade
renoviert und da hat man einfach gesagt
man baut draußen ein kleines
amphitheater who let the dogs out dank
bert neumann
da haben wir halt draußen gespielt also
gut jetzt im november das sei alles
dahin gestellt aber ich glaube man muss
eine neue beweglichkeit entwickeln
gerade weil wir noch gut finanziell
aufgestellt sind und abgesichert sind
gerade dann haben wir die verpflichtung
neu zu denken und zu handeln
das glaube ich dass wichtig weil das ist
ja über die gesellschaftlichen bereiche
insgesamt so gesehen
wir sehen einfach dass die gesellschaft
ein ja nicht so schnell ist wie die das
virus das ist einfach schneller und und
und man sieht es in den schulen ganz
stark welche welche welche
anpassungsschwierigkeiten es gibt und
und und und ich glaube man sollte da
auch gar nicht man sollte das erst mal
gar nicht so nach schuldigen suchen oder
so es ist einfach schwierig es ist
einfach schwierig das umzustellen aber
ich glaube wenn man wenn man ein
bisschen skeptisch ist was das loswerden
der angelegenheit angeht dann dann dann
wäre das jetzt die zeit sich sich dinge
zu überlegen was was was verändert diese
epidemie und künftige wenn wenn es wenn
es welche geben sollte was wir nicht
ausschließen können
ich weiß nicht wie gibt es da ideen also
das theater war lange nicht mehr so lang
anhaltend nachdenklich wie in der
pandemie zeit also in dem moment wo kaum
noch premieren rauskommen bekommen noch
kritiken zu schreiben sind ebensowenig
stattfindet hat sich der gedankliche
selbst reflexionsprozess der
theaterszene also wirklich exponentiell
vergrößert und beschleunigt und ich
finde das schon viele gute ideen auch
dabei entstehen also wie institution in
so einer pandemie situation es sind
eigentlich zwei fragen wie sie stellen
ja also wie reagiert man akut was können
wir machen in so einer situation und das
zweite ist was ist die zukunft des
systems also und damit meine ich nicht
nur die die geldfrage sondern auch die
werden wir entwöhnt von bestimmten
ritual
oder vielleicht wird das das gegenteil
sein dass wir wieder nähe suchen also
ich glaube auf der akuten ebene ist es
so dass wir tatsächlich wie
gesamtgesellschaftlich so eine debatte
führen müssen wie das system smarter
wird also dass man eigentlich die zeit
jetzt nutzt um zu differenzieren theater
funktionieren anders als museen alles
was öffnungszeiten hat ist viel
einfacher zu handeln weil die besucher
einzeln kommen einzeln durch sichere
systeme zu navigieren sind hingegen bei
anfangszeiten einfach 800 leute vor der
tür stehen die da irgendwie gebaut
werden müssen und das ist komplizierter
infektionen situation also auch
kulturelle institution funktionieren
nicht alle gleich und ich glaube systeme
können smarter werden man kann erfahrung
sammeln wo wird sich überhaupt
angesteckt was ist auch so ein vorschlag
wie von thomas ostermeier eine spielzeit
zu verschieben also ein system insgesamt
flexibler zu machen und zu sagen okay
dann spielen wir mal eine zeit im sommer
wenn das jetzt für alle so schwer ist
finde ich vollkommen diskussionswürdig
also ich bin ja eher infrastruktur
verantwortlich als selber aktuell in dem
bereich aber natürlich kann man
infrastruktur bereitstellen aber die
augen aufmacht und guckt ich sehe das
bisschen wie thomas also die debatten
sind durch die pandemie keine
grundsätzlich anderen oder die pandemie
ist nicht der ausnahmezustand gegenüber
einer normalität in der alles okay ist
da glaube ich dass kann man so
festhalten und die kreativität der
versuchen mit den dingen umzugehen
derzeit das ist schon durchaus
beeindruckend und ich hätte mir also ich
hab lange wie wie eine tibetanische
gebetsmühle gesagt wir müssen uns
bestimmten neuen herausforderung stellen
wir müssen eben gucken wie wir in
kultureinrichtungen im digitalen bereich
stärker werden wie wir
kulturelle teilhabe organisieren und
dergleichen mehr und ja es ist in der
tat richtig also nichts hat diesen
prozesse in einer weise vorangetrieben
wie die vergangenen monate war aus der
not heraus eine tugend gemacht werden
musste und da jetzt eine ganze menge im
fluss und durchaus auch positive
entwicklung geschehen
ansonsten sind wir natürlich in einer
situation in der auch noch tatsächlich
vieles möglich ist also gucken wir an
andere staaten wo er mittlerweile
komplette orchester entlassen museen zu
gemacht werden
so sind wir hier in der situation dass
im theater ja nach wie vor geprobt
werden kann wir haben zum glück jetzt
nicht die situation
ich hoffe das bleibt uns auch erspart
wie in österreich das im grunde gar
nichts mehr funktioniert sondern der
arbeitsprozesse können weitergehen
künstlerische praxis auch das kritische
fragen der künstlerischen praxis kann
weitergehen
und natürlich wird auch weiterhin daran
gearbeitet und das ist mir auch wichtig
sich mit einer situation oder sich auf
eine situation einzustellen
in der wir mit dieser pandemie
tatsächlich noch eine weile zu tun haben
werden also der impfstoff soll nicht
darüber hinwegtäuschen
und auch solche ist das jetzt mal so ein
bisschen durchhalteparolen wir machen
das jetzt alles damit weihnachten die
welt wieder in ordnung ist
es sind daher glaube ich kontraproduktiv
weil weihnachten für die welt nicht in
ordnung sein sondern wir werden noch
eine ganze weile einfach mit kontakt
beschränkungen zu leben haben wir werden
und deswegen habe ich auch gesagt mir
wäre die differenzierung als ein signal
an die kunst wichtig gewesen dass man
das wahrnimmt dass der versuche
unternommen werden sich mit dieser
situation also es geht nicht sozusagen
um das pathetische oder elitäre
abgehobene jetzt macht man uns hier zu
und es geht auch nicht allein um die
künste sondern es geht natürlich um die
frage auch in welcher welt wollen wir
leben und welche prioritätensetzung
werden eigentlich an den tag gelegt bei
solchen maßnahmen wie viel
differenzierung ist man und sind wir in
der lage aufzubringen und zwar durchaus
den angesicht der pandemie nicht die
pandemie leugnet sondern uns
auseinanderzusetzen mit denen mit den
realitäten die sie uns aufzwingen
notgedrungen aufzwingen und diese
diskussion glaube ich die müssen wir
jetzt auch weiter betreiben wenn sie
wenig da kurz nachfragen darf würden sie
eine möglichkeit sehen innerhalb der
kultur zwischen dingen zu unterscheiden
die man offen lässt und anderen die man
dann doch schließt aber natürlich das
funktioniert das haben wir jetzt überall
so
märz war ich hier am 11 weil ich der
erste der hier den läden zu gemacht hat
da noch gar keine kanzler schalte statt
weil mir klar war wir hatten die
epidemiologen hatten haben wir herrn
rosten bei unserem senat und die haben
uns ein stück weit vermittelt was man
damals über die pandemie wusste wir
wussten aber noch nichts über
schmierinfektionen aerosole
tröpfcheninfektionen das war damals
alles noch nicht klar bewusst nichts
über masken
wir wussten nichts über möglichkeiten
durch vorkehrungen ansteckungen zu
unterbinden über die rolle von
belüftungsanlagen so waren wir ja sieben
monate nicht untätig sondern wir haben
ja die belüftungsanlagen unserer
kultureinrichtungen durchgecheckt wir
haben mit expertin von der charité von
der technischen universität versucht
sehr differenzierte konzepte zu schaffen
wir wissen dass beispielsweise gesang
eine andere ansteckungsgefahr mit sich
bringt als das betrachten von bildern
liegt irgendwie auch in der natur der
sache
insofern wir haben schon längst begonnen
glaube ich ein abgestuftes
differenziertes system zu entwickeln
innerhalb der kultur finde ich muss man
unterscheiden weil wie gesagt wie sie
sagen ein museum vollkommen andere
möglichkeiten an raum quantität an
menschen regulierbar macht gleichzeitig
gibt es unterschiedliche künstler für
ein tänzer ist ein jahr aktiven nicht
tanzen können
ein riesenverlust wir können spielen bis
wir weil sie tot umfallen auf der bühne
für sänger für musiker also man muss es
differenziert betrachten
ich weiß nicht wie es zu organisieren
wäre aber diese pauschal schließungen wo
die museen zu recht sich empören und
sagen momenten aber wir haben doch kein
personal im dem sinne wir sind eben
keine sängerchor wie auch immer ich
glaube dass es notwendig weil sonst ist
das irgendwann wie gesagt auch im
vergleich zu den anderen
wirtschaftsbereichen die offen haben
dürfen wo leute ganz anders
aufeinandertreffen nicht mehr
seitens der politik uns gegenüber zu
rechtfertigen weil wir sind alle
vernünftig dass das an die schlimme
krankheit jetzt müssen wir über mich
drüber reden jeder muster den anderen
schützen nur es muss ein bisschen acht
gegeben werden wie man das macht und
man muss sich in acht nehmen vor
pauschalisierung weil die der
kunstbetrieb als solcher den gibt es
nicht vielleicht einmal eine kleine
runde zur digitalisierung das ist ja so
eine einem spontanen reaktion gewesen
und zwar in allen gesellschaftlichen
bereichen also außerhalb im bereich
lebensmittel und wenn man pizza ist eben
nicht runterladen kann aber das war ja
so bei den schulen hieß es ja das machen
wir jetzt digital in der kunst gab es
das museums führung oder man hat die
archive angezapft
was was was interessant war für für das
publikum wenn man wenn man denn ich weiß
nicht wie die zahl die nutzungszahlen
waren aber und dann gab es aber auch
darüber hinaus was ich interessant für
ein versuche jetzt das digitale nicht
einfach so als transportmechanismus zu
verwenden sondern irgendwas damit zu
machen ich sags mal so etwas pauschal
wie wir hat man haben sie schon einen
eindruck wie das also gibt es schon eine
art urteil darüber wie das gelaufen ist
es läuft ja noch und die ich glaube man
muss das und man könnte das in zwei
ebenen beschreiben das eine ist dass wir
schlagartig merken wie schlecht wir
gerüstet sind für die situation
ich glaube dass das was die meisten
theater und öffentlichen einrichtungen
jetzt gerade anschaffen was ja auch vom
staat mit großen investitionshilfen
gefördert wird ist eine infrastruktur
die nie wieder verschwinden wird also
das was jetzt sozusagen als eine
zusätzliche sparte in den meisten
institutionen entsteht die eine mischung
aus anderen kommunikationsformen in
echtzeit an den produktionen die für
diese sparte entstehen aber eben auch
das eigene archiv sozusagen zum teil des
spielplans wird das ist etwas das
braucht anderes technisches know-how es
braucht andere infrastrukturen
es braucht mehr und andere personen also
die in den theatern auch so einfach
nicht vorhanden sind
und da glaube ich ist eine riesige
einsicht jetzt am zu beobachten dass
diese entwicklung nicht zu stoppen ist
das andere ist dass digitalität ja
eigentlich schon seit 30 40 jahren da
ist auf den bühnen also wenn wir
digitalität mit prinzipien wie feedback
wie sozusagen echtzeit
bildgebungsverfahren die zusagen nicht
mehr aufzeichnungen sind sondern wo das
bild im moment entsteht andere
distributionen und beteiligungsformen
entstehen das ist etwas das hat die
erzählform die produktions form von
theater seit mindestens zwanzig dreißig
jahren radikal verändert und fingen den
60er jahren eben auch an mit 59
kunstströmungen die nicht die
technologie auf die bühne stellen also
die neue zeit begann bei shakespeare
nicht dadurch dass die bühne ständig
voll mit ferngläsern und mikroskopen
sondern dass das subjektive verhältnis
das individuelle zur welt sich verändert
ja dass sie vom typus zum individuum das
völlig andere probleme lagen auf einmal
in den stücken bearbeiten als das noch
in einem jahr kirchen spiel war oder in
einem mysterienspiel das sind die
verschiebungen die sich gerade ereignen
unter dem vorzeichen digitalität und neu
ist dass auf einmal die theater selber
in die digitalen medien wechselt bislang
war die einwirkung des digitalen
zeitalters auf die mehr oder weniger
analoge erzählform des theaters zu
beobachten und plötzlich drängen
theaterkünstler und kommunikations leute
an den theatern selber in die digitalen
kanäle mit produktionen die sie dafür
entwickeln und das ist glaube ich die
spannende pionier phase in der wir
gerade sind ja ich sehe das natürlich
ein bisschen anders weil das digitale
kann es wie ich bin hier um theater zu
reden apropos unser metier ist nun mal
unser metier und das hat was mit einem
auditorium zu tun und mit menschen zu
tun und es hat auch manchmal mit technik
zu tun und es kann auch ergänzend seien
da kann man zwei wege beschreiten wir
haben auch mit zb einem theater wo ich
gerade engagiert bin im ersten lockdown
lesung gemacht kleine filmchen gedreht
alles in ihren alles gut das kann man
kunstvoller machen weniger kunstvoller
machen
es hat zeitgleich aber auch leute
gegeben die einfach gesagt haben
wir sprechen ein paar leute an ein paar
geldgeber ein paar raum geber und zum
beispiel leute die einen theater das war
natürlich im sommer im freien gegründet
haben und gesagt haben wenn die leute
nicht zu uns kommen können dann kommen
wir zu ihnen weil es gibt das fraglos
bedürfnis nach unmittelbarkeit des fr
klose bedürfnis nach einer gemeinschaft
die aus lauter semi experten besteht die
trotzdem an etwas teilhaben können sich
ein urteil erlauben können genauso
ausgesetzt sind wie diejenigen die es
gerade machen und wir haben diese
menschen haben ein theater gegründet in
wien open air das ging weil es warm war
aber das war in diesen monaten wo man
auch über digitale sachen nachdenken
kann und hatten zwischen juli und ende
september 130.000 zuschauer
das heißt es gibt ein bedürfnis das ist
das eine
dass man das andere ergänzen kann und
ich finde es immer noch ein unterschied
ich bin wahnsinnig dankbar dass ich auf
literaturarchiv in bibliotheken dass ich
darauf zugreifen kann
aber schon bei der kunst jetzt in wien
hat auch gerade das wien museum seine
archive geöffnet und digital zur
verfügung gestellt es ist ganz großartig
und trotzdem ist schon das was ich als
alleine als individuum erleben kann
gegenüber einem kunstwerk was beim buch
leichter ist wenn ich das sozusagen
digital wahrnehme
ist es schon in die gegenwart eines
kunstwerks rein von den von der sinnen
erfahrung her etwas anderes geschweige
denn eben wenn ich sozusagen weil
theater kann ich natürlich digital
erfahren kann zwischendurch aufs klo
gehen chips essen oder ich weiß nicht
was ich bin nicht wirklich gezwungen
mich damit auseinander zu setzen und sei
es dass ich den saal verlassen wie ich
es sozusagen live gezwungen und genötigt
bin in diesem komischen gemeinsamen ist
die molands raum der zu gedanken und
empathie anregungen oder vielleicht auch
gerade nicht vielleicht nur zu wut oder
gleichgültigkeit aber der irgendetwas
mit mir macht das ist ja schon eine
andere stimmung in einem theatersaal als
in einem kinosaal
oder wenn ich alleine vom computer sitze
es ist etwas dazwischen das heißt es ist
nicht mehr unmittelbar und wir leben
davon von der unmittelbarkeit aber dass
gar kein widerspruch zu dem was ich
sagte also ich hab das genau ich hab das
genau das war das was ich meine was
jetzt wirklich wenn wir über die
deutschen theater reden oder
deutschsprachigen theater wir sind in
dem absoluten luxus dass wir uns onkels
haben das hat zwar eine staatsoper auch
ein fixes orchester nur die künstler die
dort auftreten sind oft international
wir haben die chance eben das meine ich
auch wenn wir eingeschränkt sind durch
die krise uns vielleicht auch ein bissel
zu besinnen auf so etwas wie auch wenn
es schon mittlerweile verschrien ist
weil man ja so wahnsinnig immer am markt
sein muss auf so etwas wie ein zombie wo
man sagt wer es eigentlich vor ort sei
es an regisseuren also müssen die auch
immer durch die gegend reisen oder
müssen die acht inszenierungen pro jahr
machen ohne sich vielleicht eventuell
richtig vorbereiten zu können weil der
markt es verlangt jetzt sind wir alle
ausgebremst
ich wünsche jedem ganz viel arbeit ich
wünsche jedem ganz viel geld nur ist
vielleicht auch da dieses andere tempo
es hat was ja mit das jetzt zeit
vergehen darf oder muss gezwungener
weise kann man vielleicht das auch
nutzen dass man sagt nun ja da haben wir
jemand
sei es ein regisseur oder die und die
gruppe von leuten wenn die gut
zusammenarbeiten
vielleicht macht er mal zwei sachen
hintereinander wenn er sowieso schon da
ist das meinte ich vorhin auch mit
strukturveränderungen
aber die branche selbst reagiert noch
sehr langsam wir haben jetzt selbst ich
möchte das nicht angreifen weil es ist
eine wunderbare erfindung zum beispiel
so etwas wie der nestroy dieser preis
der vergeben wird in österreich der
wurde dieses jahr vergeben warum die
spielzeit hat nicht stattgefunden ich
finde das so ungerecht den vielen leuten
die nicht ihre arbeit zeigen konnten
auch das theatertreffen ich finde da
muss man neu darüber nachdenken und
sagen in diesen zeiten was soll das wer
das glück hat der zeit dass er was
machen kommt oder nicht das lassen wir
ausfallen und konzentrieren das und
nehmen alle meinetwegen neben den
zeitraum fassenden größer oder wie
thomas sagte spielen im sommer
wo es doch kurz ich hatte das schon beim
letzten lockdown vorgeschlagen da hieß
es so nie machen wenn ich im sommer
ich glaube diesen sommer wenn das noch
weitergeht wird das anders aussehen dass
man sagt dann verschiebt sich was und
die leute werden kommen das weiß man aus
genügend anderen erfahrungen jetzt aus
dem ersten lockdown die werden kommen
nach dem motto die sind alle in den
ferien oder so schauen wir mal wie viele
leute die wie viel geld die haben noch
um wenn die ferien zu fahren außerdem
sind die ausgehungerte werden wollen und
die werden kommen also ich glaube wir
müssen ein beweglicher werden ist denn
das vielleicht ein oberländer die frage
wenn wir das jetzt hier in berlin
diskutieren
würde man die diskussion genauso in
lübeck führen oder in regensburg oder
wir haben ja in deutschland
das phänomen dass wir drei sparten
häusern in thüringen mit der straßenbahn
erreichen können
von einem drei sparten haus zum nächsten
also wir haben eine sehr dichte
besetzung des landes mit mit mit mit
oper und theater und ballett aber ist
die ist die szene sozusagen so homogen
dass alle ideen die wir jetzt sagen für
berlin uns ausdenken und sagen dann wird
das gemacht und diese chance haben wir
und da so eine ganz offene frage gilt
das gilt dass überall oder müssen wir
damit rechnen dass in konstanz und
er weiß ich nicht schwer ihn anders
gearbeitet wird und mit einem andere
möglichkeiten sind also ich glaube wir
haben in berlin eine sehr abgestufte
theaterlandschaft in die verschiedenen
ebenen funktioniert
wir haben diese traditionellen landes
oder stadteigenen oder bundeseigenen
betriebe institutionen wir haben die
produktionshäuser der freien szene und
wir haben eine freie szene die
eigentlich keine orte hat die für mich
zu den gefährlichsten akteuren in diesem
kulturellen feld zählt und matthias
lilienthal hat gestern erzählt dass in
münchen 6 prozent des kulturamtes
gekürzt wird für die nächste spielzeit
ich glaube vor uns kommen ganz
altmodische kämpfe liegen ganz
altmodische kämpfe also wo es darum geht
das schrumpfen kultureller
infrastrukturen abzuwenden
aber es geht auch wirklich ums überleben
sehr viele künstlerische akteurinnen und
akteure die in diesen üblichen
institutionen gar nicht aufgefangen
werden da gibt es zwar politische
bemühungen aber wie lange ist das
durchzuhalten er hat das gagen freier
mitarbeiter trotzdem zu 80 prozent
bezahlt werden viele von denen werden
gar nicht in institutionen engagiert wie
wird denen geholfen
das ist für mich die große frage wenn es
ums system geht und die stellt sich in
lübeck sicher härter je ärmer die
kommunen sind umso mehr wird kultur
unter druck geraten
und ich muss sagen wir haben ein
riesenglück in deutschland das mit den
niederlanden belgien vergleiche politik
kämpft hier in der regel für
institutionen also es ist nicht so dass
wir immer mal afd oder manche vertreter
aus grundsätzlich ist ja ein konsens ein
politischer konsens dass diese
infrastrukturen erhalten werden sollen
dass sie wichtig für die gesellschaft
sind wenn wir uns so stark über kultur
definieren
aber das ist das eine ja das ist die
hardware die zweite frage ist die
software also ich weiß nicht wie man das
in lübeck diskutiert aber ich finde
schon auch dass die
frage wofür diese häuser da sind was der
produkt charakter ihre werke oder dessen
ist was sie hervorbringen ob das so
immer am burgtheater bestimmt aber ich
sehe doch das ensemble theater
eigenwillig woanders stattfindet wo
leute über längere zeit kontinuierlich
miteinander arbeiten oder auch
stattfindet ja ich will das nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen und und dort
werden sich im moment ganz andere fragen
gestellt also was ist das was ihr
wichtiger weise erzählen müssen in
welcher form in dieser zeit und da kann
es sein dass in lübeck in solchen
städten schneller radikalere antworten
gegeben werden als bei uns so wie die
kunsthalle in bielefeld eben sich für
schüler geöffnet hat auch das ist eine
option wie man im moment die aufgabe in
einer krise für seine institution
beschreiben kann
liebig hat natürlich dann aber auch eine
andere verantwortung weil da gibt es
eben nur das haus und nicht zum beispiel
wie in berlin
na ja also ich sag jetzt mal natürlich
die stehen unter einem die haben eine
ganz andere verantwortung für kultur
etwas abzudecken für den kulturellen
bereich wo in einer wunderbaren stadt
wie berlin natürlich ganz andere
möglichkeiten bestehen also ich glaube
was jetzt sozusagen die ästhetischen
praktiken angeht es wird so was wie opa
weitergeben es wird konzertaufführungen
von sinfonieorchestern weitergeben da
bin ich ziemlich sicher ist wird auch
sprechtheater weitergeben und bildende
künste und performative kunst und vieles
andere das ist für mich gar nicht so die
zentrale frage die frage ist er für mich
und auch das ist nicht pandemie
zwangsläufig sondern ist eine frage die
generell natürlich eine gesellschaftlich
zu diskutierende frage ist bekomme ich
ein bisschen wieder zum ausgangspunkt
nach dem stellenwert bestimmter
gesellschaftlicher betätigung so und die
kann man natürlich je nach der nach dem
rahmenbedingungen unterschiedlich
beantworten also wir haben hier in
berlin
gerade weil ich eben finde es geht nicht
nur um die institutionen die sozusagen
als staatliche infrastruktur bereit
stehen und bespielt werden können
sondern es geht eben auch weit darüber
hinaus um die frage welche breite hat
eigentlich eine kulturelle szene
die besteht hier in berlin auf
subkulturen die besteht aus privaten
kulturbetrieben die besteht aus
einzelnen kunstschaffenden oder
kollektiven
die jetzt einen ganz anderen situationen
sind als als menschen die beispielsweise
in kurzarbeit sind in dem orchester aber
im augenblick ist gar kein kurz gestern
kurzarbeit können also spielt proben
zumindest oder streamen oder was auch
immer
dj kontrolle machen und wir haben uns
hier in berlin entschieden nicht nur
erst einmal auch zu sagen wir wollen in
diesem und kommenden jahr für unsere
institutionen die einnahme ausfälle
absichern und wir ermöglichen auch die
unterstützung von menschen die eben
aufgrund von freien verträgen jetzt
nicht spielen können unverschuldet nicht
spielen können sondern wir haben eben
auch für gerade weil berlin so viele
menschen dieser art hat im märz gleichen
programm für solo selbständige und
freiberufler aufgelegt und das auch
verbunden mit der erwartung an den bund
anders zu agieren
ich bin übrigens ein bisschen
skeptischer ich glaube 5000 euro für
sechs monate oder für fünf monate sind
jetzt nicht unbedingt der weg aus der
grundsicherung sondern wird die leute
zwingen ergänzen grundsicherung in
anspruch zu nehmen
also da gucken wir mal was da kommt und
wir haben hier in berlin ein
förderprogramm aufgelegt was
liquiditätshilfen für private
kulturbetriebe sichern soll die sonst
niemals von uns einen cent bekommen weil
die uns gar nicht brauchen also wir
machen kunst und kultur auch ohne
kulturverwaltung und ohne staatliche
alimentierung sondern die machen das im
grunde über jahre erfolgreich und sind
das erste mal in der situation von uns
unterstützung zu brauchen einfach damit
sie nach der krise noch da sind so und
natürlich denken wir jetzt auch über die
frage nach was da liquiditätshilfen im
grunde dazu führen dass diese
einrichtung sich bis auf die knochen
runter hungern müssen wenn man eine
situation erreicht das sind der
tatsächlich ein neustart ist ja auch der
name des bundesprogramms wieder möglich
ist wie können wir das ganze dann auch
anschieben und trotzdem wird die frage
irgendwann kommen
wer bezahlt das ganze und dann wieder
die frage die selbe frage auftauchen die
jetzt auch bei den massnahmen auftaucht
die am beginn der pandemie aufgetaucht
ist wo in der gesellschaftlichen
hierarchie leiter ordnen wie kulturelle
betätigung an welche zuwendung ist dafür
angemessen ist das etwas was man
notfalls auch über vier wochen oder auch
mal für fünf jahre oder auch mal für 20
jahre nicht mehr öffentlich fordern muss
oder ist es was öffentliche
unterstützung braucht damit es auch
jenseits des marktes und jenseits der in
werth sitzungs fähigen kunstproduktion
so was wie eine reflexion über
gesellschaftliche zustände darstellen
kann
da machen wir jetzt sehr viel aber ich
gebe natürlich auch keine garantie ab
dass jeder kultur
dort überlebt ich weiß nur eins wenn
hier irgendein privater kulturort stirbt
dann ist es sehr sehr schwer
wir sind nicht mehr den 90er jahren in
berlin da wieder anzuknüpfen und dann
sehe ich vermutlich wird das deine ehre
einzelhandels milliarde die jetzt offen
sind die da einzieht oder irgendwas
anderes ist die fernpass an was sie
gerade gesagt haben besteht eine gewisse
gefahr dass einfach die die die dichte
in der in deutschland auch in österreich
im grunde theater und bühnen existieren
dass das sich auflösen wird das dass das
ein effekt der krise wird sie hatten
gesagt theater im sommer und es leuchtet
ja sehr ein
das könnte man sagen da steckt aber
vielleicht den gefahren nämlich eine art
festival easy hrung des theater wer also
eine art zwischen ende mai und ende
september machen wir ein großes avignon
in verschiedenen orten und und dann
rechnet jemand nach und sagt ja dafür
brauchen wir aber nicht das aus hordel
in celle das ensemble in oberhausen oder
wo immer jetzt theater vermutet werden
können da ist das ist das 1 1
das eine gefahr oder ist das etwas wo
man sagt ja dann ist es eben so
also ich finde das theater system
verschwindet seit 30 jahren oder seit 20
und zwar von innen aber auch
kulturpolitisch strukturell und diese so
zu sagen da ist längst etwas im gange wo
ich glaube dass jetzt eine sehr günstige
zeit ist mal über das zusammenspiel von
verschiedenen regionalen landestheater
nachzudenken es gibt es alte
landestheater modell der umherziehenden
vaganten bühne quasi aber das kann auch
auf ganz anderen ebenen passieren wir
haben immer noch kein wirklich gut
gefördert das netzwerk freier
produktionshäuser das sind dinge wo ich
denke die werden kommen und zwar weil
sie kommen müssen
also ich keine anschließende ich bin da
weit entfernt davon bestimmte struktur
in bestimmte klassische produktionsstopp
touren und institutionen kultur national
offenen altar zu heben und sozusagen
dann davor zu stehen und sie mit allen
mitteln in erstarrung und also mit wachs
übergossen zu verteidigen das wäre auch
ab sofort also gesellschaft ist immer
veränderungen da sind
transformationsprozess im gang und an
diesen transformationsprozessen ist auch
viel vernünftiges und gutes und
richtiges trotzdem hat mich irre frage
natürlich erinnert an diesen witz von
unternehmensberater in ein
symphonieorchester geschickt wird und
dann mal durchchecken soll ob das alles
so effektiv ist und dann gesagt hat wir
brauchen eigentlich 16 streicher bei 4
stimmen
das können auch vier streicher machen
und dies das ist natürlich nach
allgemeiner debatte auch wieder um die
frage wie also unter welchen bedingungen
unter welchen sozialen bedingungen soll
eigentlich kultur und kunst produktion
ermöglicht werden wer soll eigentlich
den zugang dazu haben die möglichkeit
alle und an wen richten die sich also es
geht natürlich auch für mich schon
durchaus um die sierung also kunst kann
ja in der wirkung nur entfalten wenn sie
tatsächlich auch in der breite der
gesellschaft wert geschätzt wird und
wenn sie eine breite der gesellschaft
denkprozesse auseinandersetzung prozesse
auslöst und sie sind natürlich
diskussionen die wir fragen um die um
die frage welche themen werden auf der
bühne verhandelt wie findet sich
eigentlich die gesamte gesellschaft in
solchen themen wieder oder wenn sie
gruppen der gesellschaft in solchen
themen wieder die bislang in diesem
theater überhaupt keine rolle spielen
und trotzdem gibt es natürlich
andererseits auch um die frage wenn wir
ein spiel planänderung 30 stücke die das
theater heute braucht also wir spielen
ja horvath nicht weil hoffer hat 50
jahre gespielt wurde und deswegen auch
100 jahre oder 150 jahre gespielt werden
muss sondern wir spielen so ein stück
natürlich weil sie weil sie auch heute
noch eine aktualität dadurch besitzen
weil sie zeigen wie menschen in von
ihnen selbst geschaffenen sehr
widersprüchlichen situation versuchen
mit dingen klarzukommen und weil uns das
inspirieren kann und weil uns das helfen
kann bei der frage wie gehen wir
eigentlich um mit den gesellschaftlichen
verhältnissen in die wir geworden sind
und die wir natürlich auch verändern
können oder vielleicht auch gar nicht
mehr verändern wollen oder weist der
fuchs und dafür ist er da und das macht
theater spannend und da ist die frage
ich finde sommertheater super ich finde
auch draußen theater super ich habe mich
auch schon immer gefragt warum es zwei
monate im jahr geben muss in denen kein
theater irgendwas passiert
die frage kann man umgekehrt ja auch
stellen also wenn über öffentliche
mittel sondern infrastruktur
bereitgestellt wird warum findet die
nicht ganze theater staaten das heißt
nicht dass jedes theater das ganze eher
über spielen muss aber warum dann nicht
eine größere beweglichkeit reinkommt das
sind doch zum beispiel debatten auch
völlig unabhängig von der pandemie
die sind alle mal komplett
gerechtfertigt und total legitim würde
eine letzte kurze runde machen
noch mal zurück zur spielplan änderung
wie sie ursprünglich gedacht war nämlich
das steckte schon in den in der in der
in der beschreibung drin entity sierung
wie es gibt immer die produzenten die
regisseure die kulturpolitiker die
dramaturgen und so dann gibt es noch das
publikum um das publikum ist ja sie
hatten das erwähnt im sommer bereit auf
schlösser zu fahren und sich dort
konzerte anzuhören dorfplatz oder hinein
ist ist diese wie soll ich sagen dieser
versuch das theater in alle bereiche der
gesellschaft hineinzutragen hat das
grenzen ist das ein politisches projekt
es ist wunschvorstellung oder oder trägt
sich das tatsächlich zu
wir haben diese die diskussionen
durchschnittsalter des publikums haben
die die beschreibung
das sind mit manchen bereichen zu den
premieren die verwandten kommen und die
kritiker und deswegen die stücke so
schnell wieder abgesetzt werden und und
deswegen so kurze probenzeiten sind und
so weiter und so fort also wir haben ja
eine eine eine situation an den bühnen
die nicht jede beschreibung oder nicht
jede wunschvorstellungen sozusagen der
freie fahrt erlaubt weil man über sie
sagen uns na ja wo kommt man kommen denn
die leute wo zu kommen sie denn haben
sie haben sich die vorstellungen wie
sich das gibt es da einen wandel
hat das mit demokratie zu tun also dass
wir so eine letzte frage in richtung der
stücke im weitesten sinne dessen was
gespielt wird
die ich gerne stellen würde also ich
kann ja mal als aktive antworten
ich habe an allen möglichen orten
gespielt und ab jetzt auch erlebt dass
es auch dann mal nicht so gut läuft und
dass leute nicht kommen komischerweise
es liegt wirklich ganz oft autor und
also welche art von hitler also der
autor als mittler zwischen zwischen den
schauspielern die sich dann zu den
autoren machen und dem publikum das sie
erreichen wollen
wenn das sozial schwache vorlagen sind
wo die schauspieler auch wenig futter
haben weil die schauspieler wiederum
genau wie das wort mittler sind für die
leute oder an die leute man die leute
heranzukommen
dass das dann nicht so gut funktioniert
und es funktioniert immer dann und ist
vollkommen fraglos und dann erscheint
theater als so leicht wenn es mit
starken stücken und mit starken
schauspielern und vor allen dingen einer
starken regie zusammen dann dann
fruchtet das und dann muss man sich um
die zuschauer keine gedanken machen
und ich glaube da kann man jeden ins
boot holen und zur not geht man eben zu
den leuten apropos entmilitarisierung
also es trifft weit auch nur aufs
theater zuweilen der oper ist es schon
anders ich bin froh wenn ich älter 30
höhere weil es eben eine ausgebildete
sopranistin ist die ganz göttlich singt
und da möchte ich nicht irgendwen hören
ich finde es aber auch toll wenn simon
rattle in diesem wunderbaren projekt was
einmal voran war das 10 15 jahren was
war das sagte die panther oder so wo er
mit diesen kids gearbeitet hat die erst
so ankommen aber dieser film darüber
gemacht und die dann erblühen
obwohl sie vorher nichts damit zu tun
hatten weshalb ich bin von den theater
zu schauen als expertin sprach die
müssen den auto nicht kennen die müssen
in background nicht kennen dafür haben
sie uns als übersetzer sie können
vollkommen ohne vorwissen reingehen und
können sich trotzdem ein urteil
und das ist das tolle und solange dieses
solange ihnen diese chance gegeben wird
werden sie uns auch nicht abhanden
kommen das ist meine erfahrung und zwar
eine lebendige keine theorie sondern
praxis ja ich sehe jetzt ausnahmsweise
ähnlich ich denke auch dass es wertvoll
diese art von spielplan erweiterung
vorzuschlagen oder ins gespräch zu
bringen weil sie den gedächtnis raum von
theater vergrößert einfach jeder text
ist ein vorgang von geschriebener welt
die sich verlebendigt im jetzt zwischen
menschen und auch in einer sehr
speziellen weise notiert ist und dass
wieder in unser heute rein zu tragen ist
per se wertvoll
ja ich glaube dass diese stücke die da
wieder entdeckt werden wahrscheinlich
nicht das publikum ziehen weil das
publikum die stücke ja gar nicht kennt
aber vielleicht helfen sie das denken
von theater künstlern die sehr mit
texten arbeiten mit dieser art von text
arbeiten wollen reicher zu machen
anregender überraschender querstehender
tiefer und dann dann wäre schon die
mission erfüllt ich glaube nicht dass
die relevanz des theaters systems
insgesamt durch neue stücke zu nehmen
wird oder alte stücke sondern sie lebt
immer von diesem übersetzungs vorgang
der text an sich ist ja sozusagen tod im
theater sondern er braucht diese art von
wiedergeburt im verhalten einer gruppe
von menschen und was die bewegt ist
wichtig was die wird durch den text
lernen entdecken für abenteuer erleben
das ist das was mich mitnimmt wenn ich
im theater werden
dafür braucht man vielleicht nicht nur
diese stücke aber sie sind schon mal
eine riesige hilfe und ich glaube es
sind letztlich drei bis vier prozent
statistisch eine stadtbevölkerung die
ins theater gehen das ist immerhin mehr
als zum fußball
aber man soll sich nicht die illusion
machen dass wir die gesellschaft
erreichen das tun wir nicht
das gab mal theaterkünstler und ich
glaube auch milo rau würde das immer
noch wollen und losziehen in alle
möglichen bereiche des lebens um es mit
theater zu infiltrieren
aber ich glaube nach dem living vierter
ist es in dieser institutionalisierten
form wie wir jetzt hier gerade über
theater sprechen oder die wir damit
zumindest verbinden ausgeschlossen dass
wir über diese drei prozent hinauskommen
und da können wir nur glaube ich maximal
verunsichernd wirken und euphorisierend
und begeisternd in dieser kleinen blase
von menschen die bereit sind auf dieser
reise zu gehen wenn sie in theater gehen
also das glaube ich wird der spielplan
nicht für die gesamtheit relevanter
machen der geänderte aber er wird
vielleicht das spiel interessanter
machen also ich glaube erst mal und
kriegt das auch bestätigt in dem was ich
so sehe und das ist ja weit mehr als die
institutionen ja das ist kulturelle
bildung das sind bibliotheken als ritter
orte jugendkunstschulen musikschulen
dass grundsätzlich jeder mensch durch
künstlerisch ästhetische ausdrucksform
erreichbar ist also dem grunde nach
das ist erstmal ganz banal und wenn man
die frage gestellt was ist ihr
politisches programm also politisches
programm ist für mich zu ermöglichen
und diejenigen die als praktikerinnen
und praktiker diese prozesse betreiben
das hat man immer eigentlichen cola
kollaborativer prozess also mit alten
stoffen tolle neue sachen machen
gegenwartsfragen stellen oder auch meine
vergangenheit fragen stellen kann ja
auch mal schön sein müssen trotz alledem
glaube ich reflektieren sie sind ja
soziale wesen teil der gesellschaft das
ist schon ihre aufgabe weil
kulturpolitisch natürlich eins richtig
und relevant ist wir stellen öffentliche
ressourcen bereiten nicht zu knapp ich
sage natürlich immer noch viel zu wenig
es könnte mehr sein aber jammern wir
nicht in der bundesrepublik und auch
hier in berlin jammern auf hohem niveau
also dafür die kulturetats uns anschauen
und die abgesicherte von kulturellen
institutionen und prozessen und auch
förderprogramme bei allem was der
verbesserungswürdig ist
grund grundsätzlich gilt sind
öffentliche ressourcen die dort
eingesetzt werden und diese öffentlichen
ressourcen dienen und müssen am ende
einen öffentlichen zweck bieten sie
müssen sich sozusagen vor der
öffentlichkeit auch rechtfertigen
und das ist der auftrag und dieser
auftrag den den hab ich nicht als
kulturpolitisches programm durchzusetzen
ich kann aber in der infrastruktur
bereitstellen damit menschen in der
ihnen eigenen freiheit künstlerisch
tätig zu sein sich mit dieser frage
auseinandersetzen oder nicht alles
anderes gesellschaft ich glaube das
waren drei sehr gutes schlusswort ich
bedanke mich sehr für die diskussion
grüße ins publikum
auch wenn das publikum dann der aufnahme
und haben sie einen guten nachhauseweg
[Musik]